bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle trilogie de vidéo
dédiée à l'univers de Game of Thrones et
plus particulièrement cette fois-ci à la
série House of the Dragon's Mestre
Thibault herof et moi-même vous
proposons sur chacune de nos chaînes une
vidéo liée à l'univers du coup de House
et de Game of Thrones et où chacun
apparaît dans la vidéo des autres nous
sommes très heureux de reproduire cet
exercice qui vous avez beaucoup plu à
l'époque et bah on espère que cette
fois-ci cela vous plaira encore une fois
en tout cas c'est un véritable plaisir
que de replonger dans l'univers de Game
of Thrones c'est clairement quelque
chose qui m'avait manqué et je
n'attendais qu'une chose c'était de
trouver un moyen de vous parler de la
nouvelle série et effectivement le sujet
n'est pas si facile que l'on pourrait le
penser à ou ce se déroule dans le passé
172 ans avant Game of Thrones
précisément et du coup bah cela signifie
que l'on connaît le futur sans oublier
également que la danse des dragons et ce
qui se passe avant sont des événements
tirés du livre fire un blog donc en soit
c'est pareil on connaît les grandes
lignes de la série et son avenir
néanmoins la série apporte quand même
son propre canon House est prévu pour
avoir plusieurs saisons au moins 4 si je
ne dis pas de bêtises et par conséquent
il y aura quand même du mystère et des
zones d'ombre et justement rien qu'avec
les premiers épisodes il y en a une que
j'aimerais exploiter car son impact peut
révéler beaucoup de choses pour l'avenir
de la série bien évidemment je sais que
c'est une crainte partagée par beaucoup
mais rassurez-vous on ne va pas spoiler
les grands événements du livre fire and
blood tout ce qui est relié en gros à
house of the Dragon's donc voilà il n'y
a aucune inquiétude là dessus on va
seulement se baser sur les quatre
épisodes de House la série Game of
Thrones dans sa globalité du coup et
voilà c'est déjà amplement suffisant
donc si vous n'avez pas vu tout ça bah
du coup voilà vous êtes prévenus sur ce
commençons l'analyse saupoudrer de
quelques petites théories pour
agrémenter le tout
[Musique]
la série House of the Dragon's commence
très fort les showrunner ont clairement
voulu respecter l'univers de jaar Martin
qui est d'ailleurs lui aussi toujours
impliqué dans les projets et du coup
nous retrouvons une forte loyauté à
l'univers et les codes qu'instaurer la
série Game of Thrones que ce soit la
politique le jeu de pouvoir les dramas
et autres manipulations familiales
l'héritage etc etc et en soit tout ça ce
n'est pas non plus très étonnant quand
on sait que Martine ainsi kedge bio
souhaite développer un univers très
vaste concernant les productions
télévisuelles les créateurs ont un réel
désir de nous proposer à terme un
univers cohérent relié de par les séries
et qui se répondent et par conséquent en
rapport avec ceci il y a une thématique
dans House qui pour le moment reste
plutôt dans l'ombre et qui pour moi ne
va pas tarder à réellement émerger en
puissance c'est le cas de la magie et
tout ce côté spirituel et mystique
qu'apportait Game of Thrones c'est à
dire par exemple les marcheurs blancs
bras de la cornée à trois yeux le culte
de roller avec les prêtres et prêtresse
rouges etc etc malgré la présence de
dragons house of the Dragon's reste
quand même très terre à terre pour le
moment néanmoins pour moi il y a quelque
chose dans l'épisode 1 qui va permettre
de débloquer toute cette partie mystique
et c'est un peu l'objet principal de la
vidéo c'est l'impact du rêve des Gon le
Conquérant partagé par Viserys à sa
fille ranira pour plus de précisions et
Gonne le conquérant et le fondateur de
la dynastie des Targaryen c'est l'homme
qui a conquis et unifié les royaumes de
Westeros il est celui qui a fondé
Port-Réal et le Trône de Fer sauf que ce
qui est très intéressant avec cette
histoire c'est que du point de vue de la
série Game of Thrones on nous apprenait
dans la première saison par le biais de
genre à Mormon Kegon Targaryen n'avait
aucun droit sur Westeros et du coup sa
conquête d'unifier les royaumes sous une
seule et même couronne la sienne a été
justifier simplement du fait Kegon avait
le pouvoir de réaliser un tel exploit
grâce notamment à ses dragons néanmoins
la série House of the Dragon's nous
révèle tout autre chose au moment où
viserris s'entretient seul à seul avec
sa fille Rania pour la désigner en tant
qu'héritière légitime du trône de fer
viserris nous apprend qu'il gone le
Conquérant son ancêtre n'a pas conquis
Westeros par pur ambition mais à cause
d'un rêve prémonitoire une vision dans
cette vision Egon a vu la fin du monde
des hommes à cause d'un terrible hiver
qui déferlera sur Westeros et c'est
pourquoi il a unifié les royaumes sous
une seule et même couronne car en temps
voulu l'humanité devra mettre de côté le
jeu du pouvoir pour s'unir face à la
menace du froid et de l'obscurité et
parce que la condition des Targaryen est
unique de par les exploits des Gones la
dynastie ou encore leurs liens
particuliers avec les dragons il faut
que ce soit un Targaryen au pouvoir car
seul Targaryen aura le pouvoir d'unifier
tout le monde face à la terrible menace
à venir mais surtout car du sang des
Gones le Conquérant naîtra le prince qui
fut promis la réincarnation d'azoraï et
ce secret partagé par Egon n'est
transmis que de roi en héritier depuis
son règne c'est pourquoi personne
n'était au courant viserris la transmis
à raniera car il a fait d'elle son
héritière officielle et lui a fait
promettre de garder ce secret quoi qu'il
en coûte bon du coup les experts de Game
of Thrones savent pertinemment quelle
est la menace qui est gone le Conquérant
a vu dans son rêve il s'agit bien
évidemment des marcheurs blancs guidés
par le roi de la nuit sauf que le
symbolisme du rêve d'Egon va beaucoup
plus loin puisqu'à terme vous le savez
ce sont les Targaryens qui seront la clé
de l'histoire Daenerys Targaryen qui
comme son ancêtre régonne accompagné de
ses trois dragons va reconquérir
Westeros et cette dernière jouera un
rôle crucial lors de la bataille de la
longue nuit de part sa légitimité pour
le Trône de Fer en tant que fille
d'aéris II alias le roi fou lors de sa
conquête Daenerys va accumuler
énormément depuis puissance et d'alliés
pour faire face à terme au marcheur
blanc et bien évidemment comment ne pas
mentionner l'une des pièces maîtresses
de l'histoire John snow qui à l'origine
est un descendant Targaryen de son vrai
nom Egon le fils caché de regar
Targaryen le frère de Daenerys et de
Liana Stark la sœur d'ederstark il a été
ressuscité par roller le dieu de la
lumière car sa mission n'était pas
terminée il a permis à terme d'unifier
totalement l'humanité pour combattre le
roi de la nuit et libère sans fin qu'il
accompagne et pour aller un peu plus
loin dans le symbole viserris nous
apprend que le rêve de son ancêtre a été
désigné par eggone comme the song of As
and Fire qui est le titre donné par
Samuel au livre retraçant l'épopée de
Game of Thrones d'ailleurs viserris est
en possession de la date de ancêtres et
Gonne le Conquérant ou sur la lame et
carrément inscrit la chanson du feu et
de la glace soit son rêve et comme Game
of Thrones et rempli de symbolismes
c'est justement cette dague qui tuera le
roi de la nuit la menace de l'Éternel
hiver bref bon c'est bien sympathique
c'est explications et ses détails mais
pourquoi est-ce que je fais un focus sur
le rêve d'Egon le Conquérant par rapport
du coup à la série House of the Dragon's
et bien la vision des Gones n'est pas
qu'un simple rêve car de part les
événements de Game of Thrones cela veut
donc dire que nous sommes face à une
véritable prophétie et viserrissent le
confirme d'ailleurs dans l'épisode 4 et
du coup en plus de ça c'est une
prophétie qui dure et oriente l'histoire
de Game of Thrones depuis la création du
Trône de Fer et ce n'est vraiment pas
quelque chose d'anodin car la présence
d'une telle prophétie modifie clairement
la perception du scénario et le récit
porte l'entièreté de l'univers Game of
Thrones c'est la confirmation que la
série est guidée par le destin que
chaque action chaque élément est orienté
pour qu'à terme house of the dragon se
permettent l'arrivée de Game of Thrones
et du coup l'émergence de Jon Snow et
surtout Daenerys pour vaincre la menace
de l'hiver sans fin et par conséquent
pour développer cette idée et répondre à
ce que je vous disais au début de la
vidéo c'est le moment où house of the
Dragon's va apporter clairement le thème
du mystique et de tout ce qui est plus
ou moins magique Game of Thrones a été
janché de prophéties et autres vision
qui se sont réalisées au fil du scénario
accentuant tout ce délire de destin et
histoire déjà écrite Daenerys qui
parcourt la salle du trône détruite
remplie de cendres faisant écho au
moment où elle va faire un carnage en
ses invite la prophétie Daria ferment
des yeux bleus faisant référence roi de
la nuit quel tuera lors de la longue
nuit Jon Snow le fils de feu et de glace
qui a ressuscité car il avait encore des
choses à accomplir et du coup house of
the Dragon c'est de par le rêve d'Egon
allonge ses prophéties et ses éléments
du destin depuis un lointain passé nous
confirmant au final que tout est écrit
néanmoins et c'est la partie plus
théorique de la vidéo mais toutes ces
prophéties sont apportées et entretenues
par ce que j'appelle des agents du
destin dans l'univers de Game of Thrones
et comme dans beaucoup d’univers le
destin ne vient pas de nulle part si
toute l'histoire est écrite à l'avance
et que des personnages mystérieux
cherchent à ce que tout se déroule comme
prévu c'est parce que c'est l'oeuvre de
quelqu'un ou de quelque chose de
beaucoup beaucoup plus grand et
effectivement de par le rêve des Gones
qui s'avère au final être la prophétie
de la réincarnation d'Azor à rail cela
signifie que le lien entre les deux
séries et qui trace l'histoire de
l'Univers et vous le connaissez roller
le dieu de la lumière pour rappel dans
le Lord de Game of Thrones roller et le
fameux seigneur de lumière le dieu du
feu et de la vie et celui qui va donner
naissance au prince qui fut promis alias
Azor Arai néanmoins étant une croyance
due le seigneur de la lumière possède
son hémécis le grand Autre celui qui
symbolise l'obscurité le froid et la
mort bien que les récits en rapport avec
Azora fait mention d'un lointain passé
nous retrouvons bien évidemment cette
dualité dans l'ère moderne avec les
événements de Game of Thrones les
vivants contre les morts roller dans le
symbole que la vie trouve toujours son
chemin et survive face à la mort et
celui qui oriente l'histoire de Game of
Thrones et installe donc cette lourde
thématique du destin qui trace toute la
série cependant pour que sa volonté soit
faite et devienne réelle il a besoin de
partisans agissant en son nom pour
guider le monde des vivants et c'est à
ce moment où comme j'aime les appeler
les agents du destin interviennent par
de la prêtresse rouge qui a joué un rôle
crucial dans la série Game of Thrones je
veux bien entendu parler de Mélisandre
âgé de plusieurs siècles Mélissandre est
une servante du dieu de la lumière et
depuis son arrivée à Westeros elle est
l'un des réceptacle des prophéties de
roller depuis le début de la série La
Sorcière Rouge guide et oriente les
protagonistes de l'histoire de Game of
Thrones afin qu'il respecte la volonté
du dieu de la lumière et pourtant malgré
ses mauvaises interprétations comme le
fait qu'elle croyait que Stanis était le
prince qui fut promis mais licendre agit
à terme comme un véritable agent du
destin c'est elle qui nous a annoncé
Karia à les tuer le roi de la nuit c'est
elle qui a ressuscité John dont la
mission était encore inachevée c'est
elle qui nous explique pourquoi BERIC
don Darion a été ramené à la vie plus de
six fois par le dieu de la lumière ce
dernier devait survivre pour permettre à
Aria d'arriver au moment de sa rencontre
avec Mélisandre pour réaliser la que la
prêtresse rouge avait annoncé et du coup
de par le rêve des Gones et le fait que
le dieu de la lumière oriente l'histoire
de Game of Thrones depuis l'aube de
Westeros cela veut donc dire que la
série House of the dragon se va nous
compter à très fortes chances l'arrivée
de prêtre ou autre prêtresse rouge alors
il est clair que ramener Mélissandre
serait du bon fan service l'actrice de
la prêtresse n'a d'ailleurs pas hésité à
tiser les fans House se déroulant 172
ans avant Game of Thrones et Mélisandre
est tenté de plusieurs siècles il n'y
aurait donc aucune incohérence par
rapport aux dates néanmoins il est tout
à fait possible que la série nous compte
l'arrivée d'un ou d'une nouvelle adepte
du dieu de la lumière bref
baigne complètement dans cette
thématique d'élus de la série elle a été
désignée comme héritière officiel de
Viserys elle est maintenant au courant
du rêve des Gones et pour aller plus
dans le détail prenez le cas du cerf
dans l'épisode 3 de la saison on nous
répète à plusieurs reprises qu'un serre
blanc un signe et symbole royal a été
aperçu lors de l'événement de la chasse
en l'honneur d'Egon 2 le fils de Viserys
et allisent sauf qu'au final la chasse
aura menée les troupes vers un simple
cerf totalement banal et le véritable
cerf blanc se présentera devant raniera
soulignant un côté prophétique celui que
raniera et l'élément central de
l'histoire de House of the dragon et
qu'elle est destinée à accomplir de
grandes choses et bien c'est là où je
voulais vous mener puisque nous
connaissons le futur de par les
événements de Game of Thrones et que
nous savons que House of the Dragon's
nous compte la guerre civile au sein de
la famille Targaryen comme annoncé au
début de la série raniera en lien avec
la prophétie des Gones dans un but
ultime chercherait à accomplir cette
dernière c'est à dire que ranira aurait
pour objectif de maintenir et perpétuer
le destin de l'histoire des Targaryens
ainsi que son destin à elle pour KTM
Game of Thrones et tous les éléments
permettant la mise en place de la
prophétie et donc anéantir la menace des
marcheurs blancs comme prévu par roller
du coup pour permettre la mise en place
de tout ce qui a toujours été prévu
house of the Dragon's pourrait nous
amener l'arrivée ou pourquoi pas le
retour d'un ou d'une prêtresse rouge qui
guiderait ranira à accomplir son destin
dans la série le destin est une part
très importante de l'épopée Game of
Thrones et sa place dans house of the
Dragon's n'est pas à négliger malgré les
histoires de famille et les conflits
politiques la série n'hésite pas à nous
rappeler que l'origine de toutes les
actions du roi et par conséquent
l'histoire du royaume et justifiée et a
pour origine la chanson de glace et de
feu
le Conquérant malgré tout ce qu'il se
passe la magie et la thématique du
mystique sont au cœur du scénario et
risque de se décupler au fur et à mesure
que la série avance ce qui serait
d'ailleurs fou CK terme dans la série si
le rêve des Gones se diffuse dans le
palais royal c'est que chaque Targaryen
pourrait penser au final être celui qui
a pour destin de donner naissance aux
princes qui fut promis permettant à
terme de semer le doute parmi les fans
et les spectateurs après tout n'oubliez
jamais que la série à son propre canon
même si nous connaissons les grandes
lignes de la série de par les livres
nous pouvons quand même faire face à des
surprises il est sûr qu'à terme la danse
des dragons est un événement qui
intéresserait les prêtres rouges car
c'est l'occasion pour les agents du
destin d'être témoin des possibles
futurs candidats par rapport à la ligne
qui donnera naissance au prince qui fut
promis
[Musique]
c'est la fin de la vidéo et j'espère
sincèrement qu'elle vous aura plu la
série House of the Dragon vient tout
juste de débuter nous avons que quatre
épisodes d'une première saison donc nous
aurons clairement l'occasion dans
reparler proprement je pense très
sincèrement qu'à terme il y aura matière
à théorie et bah vous pouvez compter sur
moi pour explorer tout ça et vous en
parler en attendant je vous invite à
voir les vidéos de mes deux compères
liés à house of the Dragon's et où
j'apparais dedans du coup n'hésitez pas
à aller voir le retour de Mélissandre
chez Mestre Thibault et le secret des
Targaryen chez herocef sur ce n'oubliez
pas le petit pouce bleu que ce soit ici
ou chez les copains n'hésitez pas non
plus à laisser un commentaire et surtout
bah à vous abonner à nos chaînes Youtube
je pense que nous aurons l'occasion de
refaire des trilogies voilà c'était
argorock et que le lionhe soit avec vous
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]